Si tomas 10000 personas al azar, 9999 tienen algo en común.
sus intereses en negocios yacen sobre o cerca de la superficie de la Tierra.
Lo extraño es un astrónomo, y yo soy uno de esa extraña casta.
(Risas)
Mi charla será en dos partes. Primero hablaré como astrónomo,
y luego como miembro preocupado de la raza humana.
Pero comencemos recordando que Darwin demostró
cómo somos el resultado de cuatro billones de años de evolución.
Y lo que intentamos hacer en astronomía y cosmología
es retroceder hasta antes del simple comienzo de Darwin,
para establecer a nuestra Tierra en un contexto cósmico.
Y déjenme pasar algunas diapositivas.
Este fue el impacto que ocurrió la semana pasada en un cometa.
Si hubieran mandado una atómica, hubiera sido un poco más espectacular
que lo que en realidad ocurrió el Lunes pasado.
He ahí otro proyecto para la NASA.
Ese es Marte desde el European Mars Express, y a fin de año.
El dibujo de este artista se convirtió en realidad
cuando un paracaídas descendió en Titán, la gigante luna de Saturno.
Aterrizó en la superficie. Estas son imágenes tomadas durante el descenso.
Eso parece una línea costera.
Lo es, de hecho, pero el océano es metano líquido --
la temperatura -170 grados centígrados.
Si vamos más allá de nuestro sistema solar,
hemos aprendido que las estrellas no son lucecitas tintineantes.
Cada una es como un sol con una colección de planetas orbitando a su alrededor,
y vemos lugares donde se están formando estrellas,
como la Nebulosa Aguila. Vemos estrellas muriendo.
En seis billones de años, el sol se verá así.
Y algunas estrellas mueren espectacularmente en una explosión supernova,
dejando despojos así.
En una escala aún mayor, vemos galaxias enteras de estrellas.
Vemos enteros ecosistemas donde el gas es reciclado.
Y para el cosmólogo,
estas galaxias son sólo los átomos, así si lo fueran, de la inmensa escala del universo.
esta foto muestra un pedazo de cielo
tan pequeña que requerirían como 100 parches
para cubrir la luna llena en el cielo.
A través de un pequeño telescopio, esto se vería bastante vacío,
pero ven aquí cientos de pequeñas, tenues manchas.
Cada una es una galaxia, muy parecida a la nuestra o Andrómeda,
pero se ven tan pequeñas y tenues porque su luz
recorrió 10 billones de años luz para llegar a nosotros.
Las estrellas en esas galaxias probablemente no tienen planetas a su alrededor.
La efímera chance de vida allí -- eso es porque no hubo tiempo
para la fusión nuclear en las estrellas de hacer silicio y carbono y hierro,
los bloques de construcción para los planetas y la vida.
Creemos que todo esto emergió de un Big Bang --
un estado caliente y denso. Pero, cómo ese amorfo Big Bang
se convirtió en nuestro complejo cosmos?
Les voy a mostrar una simulación
10 elevado a la 16 veces más rápido que el tiempo real,
que muestra un parche del universo donde las expansiones fueron registradas.
Pero, como ven, a medida que el tiempo avanza en giga-años en la parte inferior,
verán que las estructuras evolucionan a medida que la gravedad se alimenta
de las pequeñas, densas irregularidades, y las estructuras se desarrollan.
Y acabaríamos después de 13 billones de años
con algo similar a nuestro propio universo.
Y comparamos esos universos simulados como esos --
les voy a mostrar una mejor simulación al final de mi charla --
con lo que realmente vemos en el cielo.
Bien, podemos reastrear cosas a las etapas más tempranas del Big Bang,
pero aún no sabemos qué hizo Bang, ni por qué lo hizo.
Ese es un desafío para la ciencia del siglo 21.
Si mi grupo de investigación tuviera un logo, sería esta imagen aquí:
un Uroboros, donde pueden ver el micro-mundo a la izquierda --
el mundo cuántico -- y a la derecha
el universo a gran-escala, de planetas, estrellas y galaxias.
Sabemos que nuestros universos están unidos --
vínculos entre izquierda y derecha.
El mundo cotidiano está determinado por átomos,
cómo se adhieren juntos para formar moléculas.
Las estrellas se alimentan por cómo reaccionan los núcleos de esos átomos entre ellos.
Y como hemos aprendido en estos últimos años, las galaxias se mantienen juntas
por la atracción gravitacional de la 'materia oscura':
partículas en inmensas aglomeraciones, mucho más pequeñas incluso que el núcleo atómico.
Pero nos gustaría saber la síntesis simbolizada en lo más alto.
El micro-mundo cuántico está entendido.
En la mano derecha, la gravedad las mantiene unidas. Einstein explicó eso.
Pero la asignatura pendiente para la ciencia del siglo veintiuno
es la de unir el cosmos y el micro-mundo
en una teoría unificada -- simbolizada, gastronómicamente
por sobre encima de esa imagen. (Risas)
Y hasta que tengamos esa síntesis
no podremos entender el mismísimo comienzo de nuestro universo
porque cuando nuestro universo era del tamaño de un átomo,
los efectos cuánticos podían mezclarlo todo.
Y por eso necesitamos una teoría que unifique lo muy grande y lo muy pequeño,
que aún no tenemos.
Una idea, incidente --
y voy a correr el riesgo de especular de aquí en adelante --
-- es que nuestro Big Bang no fue el único.
Una idea es que nuestro universo tridimensional
pueda estar embebido en un espacio polidimensional
así como ustedes pueden imaginar acerca de estas hojas de papel.
Pueden imaginar homrigas en uno de ellas
pensando que es un universo bidimensional,
sin estar concientes de otra población de hormigas en la otra.
Así puede haber otro universo a un milímetro de nosotros,
pero no podríamos percibirlo, porque ese milímetro
está contenido en una cuarta dimensión espacial,
y nosotros estamos atrapados en nuestras tres.
Y por eso creemos que que puede haber mucho más sobre la realidad física
que lo que comunmente hemos llamado nuestro universo --
el resultado de nuestro Big Bang. Y he aquí otra imagen.
La parte inferior derecha respresenta nuestro universo,
que en el horizonte no pasa de eso,
pero eso es sólo una burbuja, de alguna manera, en una realidad más vasta.
Muchas personas sospechan que así como pasamos de creer
en un solo sistema solar a zillones de sistemas solares,
de una galaxia a muchas galaxias,
tenemos que pasar de un solo Big Bang a muchos Big Bangs.
Quizas estos Big Bangs muestren
una inmensa variedad de propiedades.
Ahora bien, regresemos a esta imagen.
Hay un desafío simbolizado en la parte superior,
pero hay otro desafío para la ciencia en la parte inferior.
No sólo se quiere sintetizar lo muy grande y lo muy chico,
sino que queremos entender lo 'muy complejo'.
Y lo más complejo somos nosotros,
entre medio de los átomos y las estrellas.
Dependemos de las estrellas para hacer los atomos de los que estamos hechos.
Dependemos de la química para determinar nuestra compleja estructura.
Claramente tenemos que ser grandes, comparados con los átomos,
Para tener una capa sobre otra y formar una estructura compleja.
Claramente tenemos que ser pequeños, comparados con las estrellas y planetas --
de otra forma nos aplastaría la gravedad. Y de hecho, estamos en el medio.
Requieren tantos cuerpos humanos para llenar el sol
como átomos hay en cada uno de nosotros.
La razón geométrica de masa en un protón
y la masa en el Sol es de 50 kilogramos,
que es aproximadamente la masa de cada persona aquí.
Bueno, de la mayoría de ellas.
La ciencia de lo complejo es probablemente el mayor desafío de todos,
mayor que el muy pequeño en la izquierda
y que el muy grande en la derecha.
Y es esta ciencia,
la que no sólo ilumina nuestro entendimiento del mundo biológico,
sino que transforma nuestro mundo más rápido que nuna.
Aún más, está engendrando nuevos tipos de cambio.
Y ahora paso a la segunda parte de mi charla,
y el libro 'Nuestro Siglo Final' fue mencionado.
Si no fuera un Británico auto-adulador, habría mencionado el libro yo mismo,
y habría agregado que está disponible en tapa de papel.
(Risas)
En Estados Unidos lo llamaron 'Nuestra Hora Final'
porque a los Estadounidenses les gusta la gratificación instantánea.
(Risas)
Pero en mi tema es que en este sigle,
no sólo la ciencia ha cambiado el mundo más rápido que nunca,
sino que en muchos aspectos nuevos y diferentes.
Drogas, modificación genéticas, inteligencia artificial,
quizás hasta implantes en nuestros cerebros,
quizás cambie el ser humano en sí. Y el ser humano,
su físico y su personalidad, no han cambiado por miles de años.
Y quizás cambie en este siglo.
Es nuevo en nuestra historia.
Y el impacto humano en el medio ambiente -- el efecto invernadero,
extinciones masivas, etc. -- tampoco tiene precedentes.
Y por eso este siglo que se viene es un desafío.
Bio- y ciber-tecnologías son ambientalmente benignas
en tanto ofrecen maravillosas propuestas,
mientras, además, alivian la presión en energía y recursos.
Pero tendrán un lado oscuro también.
En nuestro mundo interconectado, las tecnologías nóveles pueden impulsar
a un fanático,
o a algún loco con la mente de esos que diseñan viruses de computadoras,
a desatar algún tipo de desastre.
Sin duda, la catástrofe también puede desatarse de una falla técnica --
por error en vez de por terror.
E incluso la más mínima probabilidad de catástrofe es inaceptable
si el resultado puede ser una consequencia a nivel global.
De hecho, hace unos años, Bill Joy escribió un artículo
expresando tremenda preocupación acerca de que los robots nos conquistaran, etc.
Yo no comparto todo eso,
pero es interesante que él tuvo una simple solución.
Lo que él llamó renunciamiento fino.
Quería abandonar los tipos peligrosos de ciencia
y conservar los buenos. Bien, eso es absurdamente ingenuo por dos razones:
Primero, cualquier descubrimiento científico tiene consequencias tanto benignas
como malignas.
Y además, cuando un científico hace un descubrimiento,
él o ella normalmente no tienen idea de las aplicaciones que va a tener.
Y lo que esto sifnifica, es que debemos aceptar los riesgos
si vamos a disfrutar de los beneficios de la ciencia.
Tenemos que aceptar que van a haber riesgos.
Y yo creo que vamos a volver a lo que sucedió en la época de post-guerra,
post-segunda guerra mundial, cuando los científicos nucleares
que habían estado envueltos en realizar la bomba atómica,
en muchos casos estuvieron preocupados de hacer todo lo que pudieran
para alertar al mundo de los peligros.
Y estaban inspirados no sólo por el joven Einstein,
que hizo el gran trabajo en relatividad, sino también en el viejo Einstein,
el icono de posters y camisetas,
que falló en sus esfuerzos de unificar las leyes de la física.
Fue prematuro. Pero fue una brújula moral --
inspiración para científicos que estaban preocupados por el control de las armas.
Y quizás la mejor persona viviente,
es alguien a quien tengo el privilegio de conocer, Joe Rothblatt.
Igual de desordenada es su oficina, como pueden ver.
Tiene 96 años de edad, y es fundador del movimiento Pugwash.
Persuadió a Einstein, como último acto,
para que firmara el famoso memorandum de Bertrand Russell.
Y el da el ejemplo de científico preocupado.
Yo creo que hay que maniobrar a la ciencia de manera óptima,
elegir qué puertas abrir y cuáles dejar cerradas,
necesitamos más contrapartes de gente como Joseph Rothblatt.
No necesitamos sólo físicos en campaña,
necesitamos biólogos, expertos en computación,
y ambientalistas por igual.
Creo que los académicos y emprendedores independientes,
tienen una obligación especial porque tienen mayor libertad
que esos al servicio del gobierno,
o empleados de compañías sujetas a la presión comercial.
Escribí mi libro 'Nuestro Siglo Final' como científico,
sólo un científico general. Pero hay un aspecto, creo,
en que el ser un cosmólogo me dió una perspectiva especial,
y es que eso ofrece una conciencia del inmenso futuro.
Los estupendos períodos de tiempo del pasado evolutivo
son ahora parte de la cultura común --
fuera del Cinturón Bíblico Americano, esto es --
(Risas)
pero mucha gente, incluso quienes sí reconocen la teoría de la evolución,
no se percatan que aún más tiempo yace adelante.
El Sol ha brillado por cuatro billones de años y medio,
pero deberán pasar otros seis billones antes de que se quede sin combustible.
En esa esquemática imagen, una especie de imagen sin tiempo, estamos por la mitad del camino.
Y serán otros seis billones de años hasta que eso ocurra,
y toda vida en la Tierra sea vaporizada.
Hay una tendencia ignorante de imaginar que los humanos van a estar allí,
contemplando el ocaso del Sol,
pero cualquier vida e inteligencia que exista entonces
va a ser tan diferente de nosotros como nosotros lo somos de las bacterias.
El desarrollo de la inteligencia y complejidad
aún tiene un camino inmenso por recorrer, aquí en la Tierra y más allá.
Así que aún estamos en el comienzo del surgimiento de la complejidad
de nuestra Tierra y más allá.
Si usted representa la vida de la Tierra con un solo año,
digamos, de Enero cuando fue creada hasta Diciembre,
el siglo 21 sería un cuarto de segundo en Junio --
una ínfima fracción de año.
Pero incluso en esta perspectiva cósmica,
nuestro siglo es muy, muy especial.
El primero en que los humanos se pueden cambiar a sí mismos y a su planeta primario.
Como tendría que haber mostrado esto antes,
no serán los humanos quienes atestiguen el punto final del Sol,
serán criaturas tan distintas a nosotros como nosotros a las bacterias.
Cuando Einstein murió en 1955,
un tributo impactante a su estatus global fue esta tira,
de Herblock en el Washington Post.
La placa dice, "Albert Einstein vivió aquí."
Y me gustaría terminar con una viñeta inspirada en esta imagen.
Hemos conocido 40 años esta imagen:
la frágil belleza de la tierra, el océano y las nubes,
contrastadas con el esteril panorama lunar
en el que los astronautas dejaron sus huellas.
Pero supongamos que unos alienígenas hubieran estado observando nuestro pálido punto azul
desde un cosmos muy lejano, no sólo por 40 años,
sino por los enteros 4.5 billones de años de historia de nuestra Tierra.
¿Qué hubieran visto?
Durante casi todo ese inmenso tiempo,
la apariencia de la Tierra hubiera cambiado muy gradualmente.
El único cambio abrupto a nivel mundial
hubiera sido un impacto importante de asteroides, o super erupciones volcánicas.
Fuera de esos breves traumas, nada sucede abruptamente.
Las masas continentales yendo y viniendo.
Las capas de hielo formándose y derritiéndose.
Sucesiones de nuevas especies que emergían, evolucionaban y se extinguían.
Pero en un lígero desliz de la historia de la Tierra,
la última millonésima parte, unos pocos miles de años,
los patrones de vegetación se alteraron mucho más rápido que hasta ahora.
Esto señaló el inicio de la agricultura.
El cambio se aceleraba a medida que la población humana crecía.
Y sucedieron cosas aún más abruptamente.
Sólo en 50 años --
eso es una centésima de una millonésima parte de la edad de la Tierra --
la cantidad de dióxido de carbono en la atmósfera empezó a aumentar,
y ominósamente rápido.
El planeta se convirtió en una emisora intensiva de ondas de radio --
el resultado neto de todas las TVs y teléfonos celulares
y transmisiones de radar. Y otra cosa más sucedió.
Objetos metálicos -- a pesar de muy pequeños, unas pocas toneladas cuanto mucho --
entraron a orbitar alrededor de la Tierra.
Algunos viajaron a las lunas y planetas.
Una raza de avanzados extraterrestres
observando nuestro sistema solar desde la lejanía
podría con confianza predecir el destino final de la Tierra en otros seis billones de años.
Pero ¿podrían haber predecido esta singularidad sin precedentes
en menos de la mitad de la vida de la Tierra?
Estas alteraciones inducidadas por los humanos
ocupando en total menos de una millonésima parte del tiempo de vida trascurrido
y aparentemente ocurriendo a una velocidad acelerada;
Si continuaran su vigilia,
qué atestiguarían estos hipotéticos alienígenas
en los próximos cien años?
¿Algún espasmo socavaría el futuro de la Tierra?
¿O se estabilizaría la biósfera?
¿O alguna clase de objeto metálico lanzado desde la Tierra
generaría nuevos oasis, una vida post-humana en algún lugar?
La ciencia hecha por el joven Einstein continuará
mientras continúe nuestra civilización. Pero para que ésta sobreviva,
necesitaremos la sabiduría del viejo Einstein --
humana, global y visionaria.
Y lo que sea que ocurra en este único y crucial siglo
resonará en el remoto futuro y quizás más allá de la misma Tierra,
más allá de la Tierra como la conocemos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplauso)